so let's start with a little bit of the
media reaction because it became very
clear very early on in the night that
Florida something really really special
was happening in Florida uh the people
over at the televised mental institution
of MSNBC uh were not happy about that we
just got my I'm told we just got
Miami-Dade this is a big one in Florida
let's take a look at okay this we got
the yeah so let's put this in some
perspective Miami-Dade County has two
and three quarter million people in 2016
this was a democratic County by 30
points Hillary Clinton won this County
by 30 points Miami-Dade is 70 percent
Hispanic it began shifting to the to the
Republicans in 2020 Donald Trump only
lost it by seven and look at this in the
mail-in and early vote which again tends
to be more democratic friendly Marco
Rubio the Republican is outright leading
in Miami-Dade County by seven points
over Val that means a democratic
Challenger in the gubernatorial race uh
interestingly we don't have numbers from
Miami-Dade County hi there I'm not they
popped up for a second was that it I was
no I flipped up to Broward to try to
reset it to see if it came in all right
so they were having some technical stuff
too uh but you could even see there I
think his name's Steve kornacki his uh
his reaction he's not happy when he see
these numbers but that's all right the
reason I'm really showing you that is to
to point out the truly incredible
reversal that has happened right here in
Miami-Dade and I am sitting in a room
with four voters of Miami-Dade four new
voters in Miami-Dade uh all who
obviously voted uh for Ron DeSantis and
I assume voted Republican but whatever
you guys did on the other things is up
to you and including for governorship
um it's incredible Hillary won
Miami-Dade which is thought of as really
a blue Speck in an otherwise really
purple State up to now now Florida is
very red obviously but she won it by 30
points last time now DeSantis won it by
11. that is so huge it is such a crazy
flip and I think it is indicative of
something much wider that is happening
largely in the Latino I don't want to
say litanks the Latino community in the
United States and that actually beared
out in some other polls and in some
other results